[Music]
so
happy wednesday listen defeating
upgraded
reptile robotic morphing opponents is
one way to become
a basketball immortal but tougher than
the goon squad and space jam 2 are the
real life players
that are playing inside of pfizer arena
in milwaukee
we're betting on a new legacy in the nba
finals welcome to the group chat live in
the bleacher report app
presented by fanduel we are your two
most underrated looney tunes that is
aaron kate dolan
from fanduel my name is cabbie richards
uh greg aubry couldn't be here with us
today
so i'm gonna be giving out the goods and
the sunset vibes
please send greg ivory with three g's
your sunset vibes on ig or or on twitter
uh tonight's game four in the suns and
the bucks series in the nba finals
phoenix leads two games to one we gave
away a ton of for another time but we
gave away a lot
a lot of free kicks in the last show and
we're gonna be giving away
more free kicks in this show we're
giving away up to five
grand in sneakers uh during the finals
and today we're giving out
six 250 dollar sneaker gift cards
throughout the show towards any pair of
kicks that you want
i'm gonna give out three pairs on the
show today then on br betting social i'm
gonna give away a pair then on
the br app going to give away a pair
then i'll be our kicks
going to give away another pair so um
stay tuned
and get that upgrade in your wardrobe
the g in greg stands for generous
and i'm feeling like greg today which is
to be generous so i'm going to start the
show
by giving away a free pair of kicks or
250 dollars
towards a free care pair kick so i need
you guys to get in the comments
and tell us what pair of sneakers would
you buy
if you got one of these gift cards last
week we were teasing
aaron about the fact that she doesn't
have any j's
in her wardrobe you spent you spent the
weekend in miami did you pick up
a new pair of kicks or a new pair of j's
kathy the last thing i was thinking
about
while i was enjoying myself in miami was
going and purchasing
some jays but i need to do it i do need
to do it they're very stylish
they've always been in but not even more
so now i feel like they're in for
especially
for girls so i definitely need to get it
there
wait you aaron you were on south beach
and you didn't have a fresh do you have
do you have at least have a fresh air in
high heels walk along ocean or collins
i was not wearing i was only wearing
excuse me heels i wasn't wearing
sneakers because it was so hot and humid
that was the last thing i was gonna do
and now i can't even walk because i was
in heels for
eight hours straight okay so we we
definitely need to get you one of these
gift cards
all this talk maybe i should be in the
comments you'll see me commenting
you should be in the comments help me
out so with all the stock of sneakers
it's time to upgrade somebody's
collection
uh i'm gonna give out a pair of uh so
i'm in the comments right now
and uh let me see here uh
oops sorry about that uh oh jordan fours
or taxi twelves okay not kyrie irving i
like that
um bad sport steaks sports takes pen to
dunk lowe's
i like that 21 sr off-whites always
iconic
i love it um let's see here uh
lebron 12 joey 31 700
not bad jordan 11 jordan 11s um
silly eric air max 97s i like that uh
i'm gonna give
you know what i'm still looking for you
know what did i do
uh some retro that never gives from away
right away
yes it's it's really because it it's
really because of g
money because he's he's so generous and
this is how we kick off jack
um you know i am gonna give uh i did see
a nice little um a jeffy ooh
nameless i like that gift right there
i don't know if you guys can see that
just a pair of kicks just over the world
that's pretty dope nameless you know
what because you you fire
you gave us that dope gift with uh
nameless you are getting a free pair of
kicks 250
uh sneaker gift card again hey we love
gifts
yeah drops kids as gifts as possible
that's how you get these gift in return
the sneaker king pj tucker will have all
of our attentions because every time he
enters the
building he has multiple pairs of heat
either on his feet or he's carrying them
in um
salute to br kicks the br kicks account
because they never miss a detail or a
pair of kicks so
uh salute to them and pj tucker let's
get into it giannis antetokounmpo
um is a unicorn who's grown into a
full-fledged
god either from asgard or atlantis i'm
not really sure where but
the greek god is in effect we asked you
on social earlier today
how many points will he score in game
four
get in the comments tell us how many
points the greek
the greek freak is putting up tonight
and at the end of the game we will dm
one person who got closest and hook you
up with 250 dollars
uh in sneaker money aaron giannis's
scoring prop
is 34 and a half points
you got the over or the under well it's
interesting cabbie giannis is actually
one of four players to have scored at
least 100
points in this first three nba finals
games his player prop
at 34 and a half seems low for a player
that just had
back-to-back 40-plus point performances
with giannis averaging
34 points in the nba finals so far i
know this is going to be a hot take
but i'm going under 34 and a half i
think this game
will be more defensive with the suns
probably changing i assume
their entire game plan they will try to
shut down
the greek freak and ultimately i'm not
saying he can't score over 30.
but i'm taking under 34.5 that's what my
gut is saying
the word on the street cabbie is that
you're not agreeing with me here
that's the correct word on the street
but before that did you wear red because
you knew you were firing off hot takes
today
is that what you brought to the group
honestly i wanted to wear purple but i
was told to change my
change my outfit and that's why i'm in
this color
well look i'm on the other side of this
debate yeah well i like i like the
transparency
it's wonderful um i like the over like
giannis is in the comfort of his home
gym at the pfizer arena he's in the
comfort of his home his own bed
which is probably like 11 feet long to
accomplish i can't even imagine
how big right uh he's got you know he's
spending time with his son liam i
believe that
him and his lady are welcoming child
number two so and also
nobody at pfizer arena is gonna be
counting upwards
mocking how long he takes to shoot a
free throw
from the free-throw line so it's a
comfortable comfortable building
the guy's been playing amazing like it
just uh
legendary he's been so amazing like at
the
at the rim in that restricted area he
scored 13 of 14
buckets so he's putting in work in there
nobody can stop him in the paint
give me giannis over 34 and a half
points and the bucks w
let's let's tie up this series in the
nba finals it's gonna be
a big one tonight at 9pm eastern so i'm
gonna get in the comments
i like this one uh i like this one from
uh
beastnook999 giannis 41 points 16
rebounds and
eight assists you're getting a hoodie i
like the specificity
of the line now uh
yes uh then uh not dwight
not dwight schrute 27 points
and three of them from the free throw
line just three just three well last
time he had 13. he scored 13 last game
yeah what a downgrade but i like listen
27 points three from the free-throw line
that's a hot take
dwight you're getting a you're getting a
hoodie um i like uh
let's see here let me get another one um
legendary cc ccd 32 points
for the greek freak tonight so still
under the 34.5
you're also getting a hoodie uh so
remember to keep dropping your takes
over the course of the show in the
comments
i'm gonna read a few and after the game
we're gonna pick one winner who's
closest to give away
a 250 sneaker gift card upgrade the the
summer look
and if you want to send it to aaron
dolan so she can get a pair of j's you
are welcome to do something
very much welcome because sharing is
carried
um so we also have two more pairs of
kicks to give away to in this show so
let's keep it rolling
um when the 3x2 parlay hits it's like
pete alonso in the home run dirt derby
they just
bang and again tonight fanduel is
offering
the opportunity to lock in the three by
two parlay
which is simply will there be two
three-pointers made in the first three
minutes
of the first quarter and two
three-pointers made in the first three
minutes
of the third quarter so three by twos in
both the first half
and the second half last week we locked
in the three by two parlay
and it hit let's go to the video please
we got jay crowder game high
six three pointers my guy was just on a
mission it was
right it was like j crowder in the
bubble last year with miami mikhail
bridges
thank you very much sir from the corner
that's corner that's a three by two in
the first quarter
let's let's move to the second half
drew holiday had five three-pointers
appreciate that drew
and then d book from distance
the three by two hits thank you d book
only had ten points in the game though
it was a little
a little disappointing this is the odds
boost from fanduel tonight plus four
hundred
we appreciate it the suns have hit 43
pointers in this series
the bucks have hit 39 three-pointers in
the series
we know there's firepower aaron
are you locking in the 3x2 parlay
tonight of course as i always say you
just have to bet it maybe we should make
some shirts instead of just do it just
bet it
kind of give those out here when talking
about the three by two it hit obviously
like we just saw
game two that was at plus 440. it's now
plus 400 so still great value for this
game
but i wouldn't bet your entire bank roll
on this definitely sprinkle some money
on this because it's obviously super fun
some players to kind of keep an eye on
cp3 devin booker for one they're
obviously gonna have to step
up after that game three performance and
chris middleton he always plays well at
home that's the one thing about him
and then true holiday also after that
third quarter performance last game
i think you keep an eye on him as well
for cash in this
we need you guys to get in the comments
and let us know if the three by two hits
the
three by two parlay hits and i need
names i want specific names of the
players that you believe
will hit the two three pointers in the
first quarter and the two three pointers
in the first
three minutes of the third quarter one
thing i love about you two things i love
about you aaron
you always bring so much great data and
now you're giving us
merch ideas just bedded on a t-shirt
with like the vr betting uh logo
always are we ever oh you you might need
a cut though
you might because you just you i don't
want to take it out of that i i we
haven't recorded that
this is my idea
[Laughter]
but just i'm pretty sure it's actually
stepped because i'm stealing nike's
thing but yeah
no just but no nike anyway we'll discuss
appreciate the idea though all right so
let me get into these comments here
i need names i'm looking for names in
the 3x2 parlay
let me just refresh and go right back to
the top oh you guys are
i'm i'm still screwed this is this is
dope all right
three by two okay here we go got a bunch
of
got a bunch of um totals for giannis
points which i appreciate
i'll leave i'll read a couple basketball
barbers is 29 for giannis
not zach levine appreciate you checking
in again it's the under
uh bad sports takes he's dropping 40
tonight and needs to step up tonight
40 and needs to step up bad sports takes
you're living up to your your name there
because that is a bad sports take
you need to step up um let's see here i
need some i haven't seen any names
ladies and gents uh i don't want to give
away
guys you want to get some free stuff i
got to give away a couple of hoodies
okay um ah here we go now it's
refreshing oh
salute nameless i like that you came um
with the uh
oh it's gone there oh damn what's that
actor's name again
uh shot um shia labeouf
the ship is it shia labeouf
shayla buff shyam shia labeouf i feel
like i never
thought about it
you know what it's because shea gil just
alexander just had his birthday
like two days ago in toronto and then
shay and shia la
yeah they have a similar spelling of
their first names
uh okay now zach levine thanks again to
holiday we'll catch
uh we'll catch and shoot and debunk
we'll hit one off the screen
just bend it thank you for the detail i
know you've gotten a hoodie before
you're getting another one
and uh let me get one more here um
king of sports 21 is the best bet i'm
definitely riding and it's plus 400
can't miss on this one lock for sure it
will be
crowder and drew both uh continue to be
hot from laughs
last week i need them kicks cabbie you
know what
king of sports 21 because you gave me so
much detail in the comments
and it was a fire take i know i'm only
supposed to give away hoodies
i'm gonna give you a pair of sneakers
i'm gonna move we're gonna i was
supposed to give away a pair of sneakers
in the next thing but king of sports 21
that was a dope comment you're getting a
pair of sneakers i've got a couple more
hoodies to give away um there you go now
people will start carving
there we go silly eric three by two is
hitting for sure booker hidden all three
all threes wow this is a bounce back
game for d book
silly eric i appreciate that i need some
gifts anybody got
anybody got any more any gifts okay so
last one
um last one who else needs
a hoodie go white socks
if it did hit then it's chris paul and
chris middleton
chris and chris appreciate that i like
what you did
you are getting up you're getting a
hoodie
uh i like the role players i think you
mentioned this earlier in the show
aaron about chris middleton playing
better at home role players also play
better at home
right so give me brooke lopez from the
corner pj tucker from the quarter
uh and you know devin booker for sure
has will have a bounce back game
uh mikael bridges as we saw with the 3x2
in the previous game
with the yellow kicks he's gonna drop
one it's gonna hit in game four people
i'm glad you guys are on board with with
aaron and i and the group chat we are
riding three by two parliament
absolutely
um oh so i was supposed to give away a
pair of kicks so uh king of sports 21
you got your free pair of cakes
so if you want to ride the group chat
with the group chat get on fanduel
and lock in the 3x2 parlay once again
two three-pointers made in the first
three minutes of the first quarter
and the first three minutes of the third
quarter let's get rich
plus 400. the the the only true
contenders
for finals mvp at this point are the two
first ballot hall of famers playing in
this series
that's chris paul and that's giannis
attitude attentacum
we asked you today on twitter who is
winning the mvp
cp3 at the top giannis at the top you
see the odds there
this is the graphic let us see the odds
there or the results from this twitter
poll last week
cp3 was a heavy favorite with 45 of the
vote
today people are feeling honest the
momentum has swung back to milwaukee 43
of the vote so let's take a look at the
odds the updated odds
for finals mvp we tease you there on
that other graphic
chris paul -240 heavy favorite heavy
favorite excuse me the greek god plus
220
get in the comments and and please tell
us who is winning finals mvp
and i need reasons i need the player and
i need the reason
if you want to go down the menu that's
cool too if you think devin booker
is gonna channel the black mamba and go
off
hey give us a reason why deandre hayden
was uh was pretty effective in phoenix
and they'll have potentially two more
games in phoenix where he put up big
numbers
all right so aaron have you changed your
mind from last week about who you're
locking in
the finals mvp well last week before the
game as the final is mvp
yeah so last week before game two i said
wait and take cp3 if he moves down from
minus 150 since i believed those odds
would obviously shift
they've actually moved further out in
favor of cp3 so odds makers are clearly
agreeing
that cp3 is most likely going to win the
finals mvp
mvp the value to me though is on giannis
plus 220. i could see the argument that
there is value in devin booker at 12-1
but those odds seem way too far out for
me at this point so i think it will be
either
chris paul or giannis i want to stick
with my pick of cp3
winning this award but obviously way too
much juice there but if i were to bet
into this market right now i feel like
giannis would be the play especially
if the bucks win this game but again i
do think cp3 will win it
did you win any money on the bucks game
three when you're watching miami did you
lock in
buck's money line or or the i think
there were four minus four and a half on
the points
so i knew i felt like they were going to
cover minus four and a half i wasn't
sure
you know they're a roller coaster
betting on the bucks is very
nerve-wracking for me
since they were playing at home i was
only got we were feeling the vibes
they played well i'm sorry were you
you were were you in tampa bay with the
lightning or were you in south beach
we were in south beach you're in south
beach
uh i like that i like that lifestyle
g-money always says it's a lifestyle
you are living the lifestyle well done
on a boat uh i like giannis
listen i i um and and last week i buy
into the narratives
and chris paul in year 16 if he wins
the nba championship he'll likely be the
finals mvp it's an amazing
narrative but giannis is as a dude who
came from another country and to
overcome so many barriers
that that that narrative is is more
compelling to me
and the fact that he's putting up like
shaquille o'neal
numbers in the in the finals he's
averaging 34
14 points sorry 34 points 14 rebounds
and five assists
that's like shaq in that early 2000s
repeat before you were born you probably
have maybe seen a granny clip on youtube
from
from time to time but uh that's how the
the greek god is playing right now so
i like giannis the plus 220. uh let me
get some let me get some comments from
uh from the chat right now
um all right so
let me see here nameless okay nameless
you're coming you're coming strong i
can't give you another hoodie
but you're coming strong there with the
point guard gif
that's fire right there my g well done
um
let's see not deuce tatum says giannis
because he can't be stopped
um with uh with ayton out of the game
i like that take um let's see who else
we got here
uh let's see t
campbell 14 right cp3 is a is a mortal
lock
not just a regular lock but a mortal
lock they won't pick giannis if phoenix
wins the series of course yeah
the cp3 is the engine of that ski but
to um minus 240. it really is that is
but love hearing that we have a mortal
lock in the comments
yes and then oh garrett berg13
this might be you so the the two other
accounts that i read except for nameless
you guys are getting a hoodie
garrett berg13 you're definitely getting
a hoodie because giannis is feeling
loose right now he's
do you think you'd be dancing i don't
know what one of these games do you
think that's how you get excited or do
you like put headphones in
oh you know what i feel like giannis is
a headphones guy walking through the
tunnel
yes but then but then like when it's
i don't know 10 or 15 minutes through
you know before the game then he's got
to get loose because there's so much
nervous energy
there's so much excitement in the
building there's so much excitement in
the deer district
where there's twenty-five thousand
people hearing everybody who's
dancing already like all day long yeah
yeah do they take yeah honest or they go
green free like i don't know i've never
have you been to milwaukee do you know
what they chant there no i have no idea
what they chant
i i the last thing i'm thinking about is
going to milwaukee for a game i don't
know what there is to do with milwaukee
i feel like people have been talking
about this in terms of traveling for
this series they're like
not upset that they're going to the
phoenix suns but then they have to go to
milwaukee they're like oh
milwaukee well listen the nba finals are
carrying on okay so you there's there's
game four which you can't you're not
gonna get
there's still game six which will if
there's a game six you know it's gonna
be election yeah okay so those are the
people winning hoodies
um uh oh and uh you know what i actually
have to give away a pair of kicks
so oh okay richie 21 giannis finals mvp
he's been unstoppable dropping 40 plus
points
and carrying the bucks bucks in seven
i like to give because giannis has like
one percent body fat so every time he
just moves you just see the
like the muscle fibers and i don't know
i'm getting so specific on this but
salute no he's rich 21. drift he looks
like a green screen
he's yeah i mean it's unbelievable yeah
this
i mean the tr the triceptuals and the
bisexuals are so visual
one more time okay i know we're going to
move i put my i put my arm up but it
doesn't compare
in any shape i report to that you know
you don't have the you need to do you
were on south beach you got to do the
beach muscles it's the car
i know that and the truck got it yeah i
gotta get on the machine where you pull
the rope down
um it's called the trisect extension
anyway i think
tonight's a pupil game four in in
milwaukee the tip off is at nine pm
eastern
uh the our lead in the series 2-1 as you
guys know here are this
here are the odds for the correct series
score
this takes a this is an another
prediction but there's and there's
definitely some value here
will the series end four one four two
four three for phoenix or milwaukee
get in the comments tell us which team
is winning the series and in how many
games
and you have to tell me why to get your
hoodies because just like in
high school math class you got to show
your work to get your credit
aaron before we get to your prediction
how were you in high school math
be in high school bath i did have
straight a's but i wasn't in the first
track
of it i was good at like science very
good at communication and talking in
class but other than that
math was not my strongest subject
right because science and communication
doesn't sound like algebra
or no trigonometry at all memorization
so it makes sense now for my job
communication memorizing things
especially in signs well done okay
all right so uh what is your prediction
in
in the series for the correct score you
have sons and whatever or bucks and
whatever so i have
sons and six i said this last week it
was plus 440 it's now down to plus
320 so still some great value like i
mentioned this series can go the
distance especially it's a bucks win
tonight
bucks are still very much a roller
coaster to me the entire season
they were a roller coaster to me so
after obviously this game three a lot of
people are going to think oh we'll take
the bucks
in six or seven potentially but i think
the suns are probably humbled by game
three
so i'm still going to stick with the
suns in six but cabbie i know you don't
agree with me
on this sun's winning overall we're
actually not agreeing on anything
basically in the show
but you know what it's because you went
to south beach and you didn't get a new
kick so i was like
we're already we're already fighting you
missed a huge opportunity
uh you guys make sure you get in the
comments and let us know the correct
let us know your predictions for the
correct series score uh
and i need to know reasons why like
aaron just gave a wonderful soliloquy
uh as to why the suns will win at six
and i'm going to give away some hoodies
i like the bucks in seven you're right
we are on the opposite sides here um
because
when it comes to elite teams playing at
the highest level you try to find part
of the strategy is to try to find
advantages in the margins and even
though the nba
has played now is such a perimeter game
and both teams
shoot the three very well size still
matters
and milwaukee is a tough physical bigger
team
than the phoenix even when they play
small ball they're still bigger than the
suns i'm talking about the bucks
and when deandre ayden has to sit down
and rest then
buttonholzer sends out a seven foot
brook lopez and a six
foot ten bobby portis to grab rebounds
and second chance points opportunities
and if chris middleton plays at his
all-star caliber
level the bucks can steal either game
five in phoenix
and or steal game seven in phoenix so
give me
bucks in seven i wanna see this be an
absolute classic series
that's what i got okay so let me uh let
me quickly go to the comments
and see what we got here are we seeing
any sunset box are we still getting
people doing that
uh sunset vibes i haven't seen any
sunset vibes but i do have uh
uh let's see here we got um not deuce
tatum is back
bucks in bucks in six holiday finds his
groove i like that
okay drew holiday at 21-9 in his
last game game six against atlanta he
had 27.99 so
he's got it in him for a big game it'd
be nice to see dude with games sons
sons game five chris paul will be on
fire booker will be a
a shooter and aiden will grab anything
dude with game you are getting a hoodie
well done sir
uh let me see if i can now dro 305
suns in seven four three cp3 and the
sun's taking in seven but giannis is
putting up huge numbers
uh uh in game four i like that
uh let me try to find another oh let me
okay cash wavy says sons and six
booker and cp3 gonna cut down or
oh gonna cut down on turnovers and score
lights out there's a there's a um
devon booker gif uh okay
what did you make um devin booker's i
was just gonna bring that up
so kathy was making me look at devon
booker's fit as he walked through the
tunnel and
i wish i could put it on screen but it's
short
i guess that's high ankle socks or some
type of dress shoes
long sleeve red shirt and then i don't
know if that's like a levi's
white tee over i don't know what's going
on with that button down
all around you looks like a disaster and
we know he didn't like this fix he
didn't post it
but people were making that's right and
he also he he dressed like a disaster
and then he played
terribly ten points after this fit
clearly this was the issue
[Laughter]
if you have some love in the comments
for devin booker we'd love to see you
um so uh listen um
let me uh you know i'm gonna say bye i'm
gonna see
maybe maybe one more hoodie tapi10 just
has
a gif of just a bunch of sneakers i know
you want like people love the sneakers
shoe games i hope you tap into all the
people that are obsessed with them
was it shoe heads sneaker heads sneakers
new grass sneakers
um listen thank you so much for tapping
into the group chat live on the bleacher
report app
uh presented by fanduel hopefully i gave
away enough hoodies
i don't i hope i get i did greg ivory
justice because he's the most generous
dude on the crew
remember what you learned today we are
riding with the giannis over
underscoring prop which is 34 and a half
points
chris paul is still the betting favorite
to win finals mvp
but as aaron said earlier if you believe
that milwaukee can turn this thing
around
there is there's still value in giannis
to an mvp at plus 220.
get on the 3x2 parlay if you're riding
with the group chat and get on fanduel
to lock in
that bet let's ride together first half
second half
we have more kicks to give away after
the show so get on
be our betting social the br app
and be our kicks on social and that's
where we'll be giving away
three additional pairs of sneakers after
the game um
if the series goes to game six we'll be
back next tuesday when we one we'll be
giving out another six pairs of sneakers
which is fifteen hundred dollars
boom for you thank you so much for
riding with us and if you want a sneaker
a pair of sneakers or a hoodie today we
will dm you
okay and also if you do last thing if
you do
win a pair of sneakers feel free to
donate them to aaron dolan because
i do need some j's in her closet because
all she has
are our heels evidently and not even
like a pair of fans
uh listen um thank you so much for
tapping into the group chat alongside
aaron dolan
i'm cabbie richards we are leaving enjoy
game four tonight
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you